All right, um, thank you very
much everyone for coming.
Uh, today we're gonna talk about a topic that
was barely discussed this conference,
um,
and kind of under the headlines, uh,
we're gonna talk about AI.
Um,
but seriously now
I think
one of the areas where AI can make the biggest
impact is observability and, and, and
observability is
one of the closer areas to code where
AI is already making a huge impact in the world
and it's actually has the potential
to, uh, not just make our lives easier
as software engineers and platform engineers
but also
make our lives better with, uh, faster,
better software delivery, better
stability and security of software.
When we thought about it in CoreLogics,
we're trying to understand what is the highest value that we
can provide. Is it an assistant? Is it a
co-pilot?
And we came up with Ali. This session
is going to be both about how we built it
and how we came to that conclusion
of what exactly is going to be the design,
but also a bit about how you guys can build it on
your own and what are the fundamentals
that you need to build, uh, uh, an AI
agent, not just for observability, by the
way, but for any data access.
I'll start with a bit of background about CoreLogics and
ourselves. Um, I'm the co-founder, CEO
of CoreLogix.
Laon heads AI for CoreLogics right
here. I'll be the one talking more about AI.
Um,
we started CoreLogics in 2015, launched
in 2017/300
petabytes of data ingested
every day in CoreLogic, probably a much bigger number.
We raised about $400 million
so far running, uh, multi-cloud,
but primarily Amazon. CoreLogic also
was awarded this year,
um, EMEA Partner of the Year for Amazon
Marketplace.
And uh we run on 8 different
regions today, including the federal cloud
on FedRAM moderate.
I don't have to say much. Software is
complex and it's getting more and more complex
actually this thing sometimes you need to use
something that you edited or something. This is
like a small company service
map.
Uh, when we look at large scale companies, services
got so complex today it's
almost impossible
for uh a platform engineer and, and
I think it also reflected in culture
of push things towards the engineering and the
service owners just because it's impossible to
understand and grasp, uh, software systems
today. If we go back in time
when we kind of started our engineering
experience, um, maybe 1517
years ago, not, not a, not
several decades ago,
there were monoliths. You would go to the machine, you'd look at
the logs, maybe a little bit of metrics, you get a good
understanding of what's happening
these days with microservices, different deployment
models, um, multi-cloud
serverless,
your ability to actually understand what's happening in your software
is very limited.
And we think we have the solution to that.
Uh, but we'll talk about it in a minute.
Telemetry is exploding,
so people think,
OK, how do I monitor all
these microservices? How do I,
uh, get a better understanding of what's happening in my production
systems?
I'm just gonna add more telemetry. I'm gonna add
a metric. I'm gonna add a log. I'm gonna add
another instrumentation.
In just over 8 years we
see 100x,
um, this is from public sources,
100x increase in telemetry
data. What does it mean? It means that it's
complex, it means that it's expensive,
it means that it's difficult to manage,
but we're not really getting better observability, and we'll
talk about that.
The solution is the all in one dashboard.
One dashboard, it has
all that you need, all the KPIs that you're tracking.
I'm of course joking. The,
the last thing we need
is another dashboard. The last thing we need
is another alert.
The
world of just dashboarding everything and alerting
on every single possible scenario.
Uh, removes a bit of the ownership
from the service owners and the engineers towards
the services that they provide and run in production.
We think, OK, we solve the problem, we add a dashboard.
What's our definition of done for a feature? We have
dashboards and alerts set for it,
but the definition of done for a future is that we
can run it in production and keep it in high
quality and high performance.
So that
led us to build more dashboards
and alerts, and it, it feels like we got good
coverage. This is
an average of a CoreLogics customer. I'm talking
only the dashboards that are accessed and
alerts that are triggered
were in the hundreds.
Sometimes we come to customers that have 10,000 alerts,
20,000 alerts.
Can you really
comprehend the system? Do you really own
your service if it triggers 20 alerts
every day and has 100 dashboards on it?
Probably not.
This is what it'll look like.
You go into your dashboard interface. You got multiple
folders.
Many things are just, you know, duplicated
variables that you need to change to
understand your specific, uh, component.
Hundreds of alerts that are triggered, and then we built
on top of these alerts we built all these, uh,
alert aggregation tools and incident
management management tools. So we're trying to
figure out the problem, but we started with a very,
uh, kind of low state and we're trying to improve
it. There's
a paradigm now
where more dashboards, more
data, more alerts
don't mean more observability, don't
mean more reliability.
And intuitively you'd imagine.
Um, on data analytics in general,
you know, and, and a lot of us studied math or
statistics, the more data you have, the more accurate
you are. The more data points you get,
the better insights you get.
In reality, if you think about this for, for
observability and software,
what is easier? Is it easier debugging a service
with, uh, one service, 1 gigabyte of logs
every day, and 100 custom metrics,
or
billions of, uh, uh, metrics,
terabytes of data for multiple services?
Obviously it's easier when you have less.
So how do we
deal with that? Do we build more dashboards? Do we create
more alerts? Do we trim down data,
which is also a
complete industry that's started now just for filtering
data out?
We've got so much garbage we don't want to pay for it.
We start filtering out. We start optimizing.
And
The numbers I've given on dashboards and alerts,
those are only the ones that are being accessed.
92% of dashboards only
use, uh, are only used for one
week. People will create kind of
a standalone dashboard
for a specific issue they have, then they neglect,
neglect, neglect it. Now the funny
part is.
You know what's gonna happen in the next, uh,
postmortem.
The, the conclusions are we're gonna add this
dashboard now an alert,
so next time we'll know,
but you just go back and add the same
dashboard a week later, no one looks at it.
So
Engineers now have to spend
close to half their time
just triaging and understanding where should I even look,
what dash do I need to look at
out of 100 alerts, and every time there's a big incident
in large scale systems, and you know we run
one coincidentally.
Um,
when one service goes wrong,
everyone starts firing alerts and errors. So
where do I even start?
A lot of the times we start triaging and we think, oh, it's
that service. No, this is just downstream, this
is just the upstream.
So
can we do something better? Is there a way to
deal with this?
And also a big question is
how come this wasn't solved yet?
It's a big problem, and the data grows
faster than our ability to deal with it.
Now there's an opportunity
because something big happened in
technology over the past few years
and
how do we leverage that?
So let's start with the basics.
Observability is a term that we have a problem with,
uh, to be frank, and it's, it's a bit of a.
It's a bit tricky because we're an observability company,
um,
but observe is a very passive term.
Do I want to observe my systems?
I mean, imagine a.
Police officers will say
that their job is to observe the street.
We're, we're actually, you know, we need to keep systems up and
running. We don't need to observe them. Having more
monitors and dashboards
and telemetry is a great way to observe
what's the end goal.
The end goal is to have reliability,
to have stability,
to create business insights, to have
security. So
we keep building better observability,
but we kind of forgot
why we're building it and you know I can say about CoreLogics
specifically CoreLogics had invested
over $250 million in R&D
over the past 6 years.
So imagine the the amount of
engineering and R&D work that we put in
just to try to keep up with how fast
data and systems were evolving.
So we were in that arms race against
obviously a very crowded space.
But
it was very hard for us to go back to the
essence of what companies want, which
is reliability.
Ease of management,
being able to resolve issues faster, have
performance that's measurable.
Actually meet business KPIs that
drive
the revenue of the business and the customer satisfaction.
Now how do we get there?
Every software
emits
millions and trillions sometimes of data
points.
Core logics cover the entire suite, whether it's logs,
metrics, traces, infra monitoring, APM,
realism monitoring, SIM, AI monitoring.
So we, we're, we have enough signals.
We can get signals
for every, every, uh, user
action now.
But the challenge is
how do we stitch them together into a story and the
cardinality of data and the variety of data
and the multi-dimensional
aspect of it.
Create such
anthropy that to actually understand
what are the connections in a way that gives me high certainty
to take action is really complex.
And the compute that it required until now
was just impossible to employ to
solve that problem, and the data was growing so fast.
So that frog leap we've made in
technology now enables something else.
How do we now
create uh a story,
not we, we don't have an assistant to help
you build another dashboard or,
you know, a, a co-pilot that gives you
hints.
How do we autonomously and automatically
create that story from those bread crumbs?
To create a a complete new interface, a
complete new approach to observability, and go
back to the basics of
simple
and coherent insights that lead
to reliability,
performance, business KPIs.
And there comes
Ollie, and I'll hand it to LeBron.
Thank you, Ariel.
So as Ariel mentioned,
We've been focusing
on the wrong thing for the past few years,
right? We've been focusing about how we do better observability.
And we forgot why
we forgot that the key, the end
goal we are actually aiming for
is just to have reliable software.
We built something. We invested in developing the software.
We wanted our users to experience something.
And we built
crazy platforms just to observe them.
And yes, we have very, very advanced tools,
but how much do we increase reliability?
How much have we increased reliability with all these
capabilities?
And this new paradigm of AI,
right, like I think you can see it here on every
single booth,
on every vendor,
right. There
is a true and great power
to it. Which allows us
really to rethink
what is observability or
you know really reliability. How do we achieve
it and how can we actually do it
not the same way, not grow linearly,
but actually how can we do it 10 times better than
what we've done until now.
And this is where Ollie comes into the picture,
the world's first autonomous observability
agent. So
what all is doing, how it, how it
actually works, right?
So we talked about billions and trillions
of bread crumbs, logs, mattress,
uh, metrics, traces,
um, let's say.
I'm at home watching Netflix, watching Squid
Games. I click on
episode number 2.
And it doesn't work, right, or it glitches
for a few seconds, right? Quite annoying.
Not a fun evening to have.
But why it happens, so it means there's probably
something along the way, along the software stack,
right, maybe some microservice backend,
maybe a database
experiencing some issues, maybe actually another third
party application
that my app, the Netflix app is connected
through API
having some experiencing some issues.
And all these pieces
somehow result in me as
a user experiencing not even a
downtime, just a glitch
or unexpected behavior that
the original engineers actually wanted
a name for.
So this, all these pieces,
taking each and every
component, the microservices, the databases,
the lambda functions,
taking the bread crumbs of each one of them.
Potentially should tell a story of what happened
to Iran as a user,
right? And the question is not
only what happened to me personally as a user,
but what actually happens as a trend
for
more users.
Maybe there are hundreds or thousands of users experiencing
the same issue,
and what's common about all of them.
So Back to what we
see on the screen,
we see all these
billions of breadcrumbs,
right? And usually how do we do it?
We open the alerts,
try to find correlated alerts,
we deep dive into the dashboards, we
filter out for logs, say, hey, I see
there's some error logs,
right? And then I understand, oh, I see like these
services seems to be related,
right? So I further analyze.
So we have logs, we have, uh sorry, we have alerts, we
have dashboards.
And the third component
is plenty, plenty of manual
labor
going into
resolving, investigating
production incidents,
OK? So we've all, we have
all this information available not only for
us but also for Ollie,
and the beauty of it.
is that it makes everything go away.
No, OK
So Ollie takes all this information
we can give them the task.
And then it zooms in
onto out of all these billions of breadcrumbs
onto the specific most relevant pieces
to the task at hand.
And the next thing, it actually eliminates
the noise, right?
Remember, we have more and more and more and
more. We lost clarity. We got more noise.
On eliminates all this noise.
And can actually focus on the signals
that truly are important and
hopefully.
will tell my story as a user.
And most importantly, it can connect the dots
to one single story,
what the end user is experiencing
or the end users are experiencing,
all the way back
to what was the root cause of that.
Sounds too good to be true.
Yes, no.
OK. So, uh, yeah, these
are nice slides,
but I think uh the proof is in the pudding, so
let's see all the in the works.
So,
what I'm going to do now, you can see my screen, right?
Awesome.
So, nice to meet you. I'm Adam. I'm
head of platform
at um Spotify,
a sport goods companies.
And I manage the e-commerce website
and the platform team, and I'm just writing code in
the meantime.
Doing my day to day tasks.
And as I'm doing my work,
Let's see.
Oh, I got a message.
I got a message from Sarah Parks. Let's see.
So Sarah is our VP of product.
She's very good at what she's doing,
and
let me zoom in a bit.
Um, I got a message.
Adam, this doesn't look good. What's going
on? We're getting slammed with customers'
complaints. Um, and it seems like she
referred here to an alert we got on
production alert channel.
So let's take a deeper look into it.
So we can see a warning about checkout error spike.
So we're an e-commerce website.
Obviously the last part is
customers come in after they've chosen, they chose
the items they can check out
and make the purchase,
and it seems like there is an issue,
so. Instead of opening
another dashboard, let me just ask Ollie,
hey, Ollie,
um, can you please
take a look?
OK, and as I tagged Ollie,
Ollie immediately reacted, as you can see,
and it starts conducting an
investigation of what really happened,
and he shared with me
um this link so I can see
really what's going on
in real-time. Let me zoom in a bit.
OK. So
how will it work? What we are actually seeing all it works
like yet another engineer in
your team.
So think about yourself, right? You would have
looked on dashboard every time, let's say
we would have filtered for
error logs.
We would have identified some pattern, actually,
uh, let me zoom out,
um. We
would identify a pattern. Based on that, we
would probably see another filter or go to traces
or go to metrics. So in every given
point in time I have one thing on my screen.
So on the right side,
what you can see is what Ollie is currently
looking at.
So for example, right now we can see Ollie is looking
at the logs.
OK, and it's, it's, it's writing
to, it's writing to me, it's sharing with us
what it currently thinks
and what path it is exploring.
Um, and it has many capabilities whether it's exploring
logs, metrics, traces,
correlating them,
analyzing the code.
And more
OK, and we see that we got a result, so
let's see what happens.
So let me close this.
And by the way, as you can see, this is a live demo.
Decided not to go for a video.
Um, OK, so let's see.
I noticed a spike in failed checkouts
over the last 2 hours.
Dug into shopping cart API. This is
one of our services,
logs and found a new type error that correlates
exactly with the spike. It is affecting about
2000 users.
From here we can see what is the root cause.
Failed checkouts
are caused by type error exceptions in the
shopping cart API service.
Now one more thing you will see with OI
is that every time OE provides
you with information,
it backs it up with evidence.
Why? Because we know AI can hallucinate, can make up things,
and we want to make sure we can actually trust
OI. This is a key
that we put a lot, a lot of effort and
engineering resources into ensuring
the quality of OLI.
So I can see exactly the logs that
are relevant. Let me open one of them.
Uh, and we can see the message here is unsupported
operan type
and the trace back. This is a pipe service,
so I can see really what's going on.
Um, let's go on.
So where it crashes.
So Ali here actually opens the code file,
analyzed it,
and found the specific lines of
code causing the issue.
It explains that some function fails
because it tries to add in.
And none raising this error.
Why
have we gotten to this case from the get-go
that we have none
in this,
in this list of items in Python?
The reason is bug and removed from card lines
65 to 66. I can open the source
file and actually I also got
suggested fix from Ali.
So it seems
You know, not like
really quite an easy fix we hopefully
can apply.
um, also an analysis of how many
users were impacted and chart
analyzing where the issue has started,
how it looks like,
and so on.
Um, Ollie also share with you what happened,
so. Just to understand how
all it really got to this thing, it's not
magic.
There was a real in-depth
investigation that happened in this one
minute. So all the analyzed
metrics.
It tried to find relevant metrics.
It looked specific payment errors, API
errors, checkout error account.
Rain query. I won't go into each one of them,
but you can see just
this, let's say we have one.
234.
4 queries
Just think about how long would it take you just
to realize you need to write this
query and filter this out and make sure the syntax
is correct.
Realize what's the insights you're getting from it and
how you can actually continue with the investigation.
Um, usually, usually
from what we see in our customers, this time being
saved is about 94%
on average,
um, and to make it into numbers, that means
an issue
that would take me 5 hours to investigate
with all it would take about 20 minutes.
OK, Obviously
this is average. There are things that.
Finish up in a matter of 2 minutes.
Some of them take longer than that,
um, but all in all, this is extremely powerful.
OK, so now we have
we've identified the issue. Let me go back because
I don't want Sarah to be upset with me.
Um, so Nikesh, our engineering lead,
hey Nikesh.
We have a production issue.
Please take a look
on the reason.
And deploy a fix
ACP. please
keep me posted.
And I'll be sharing. Let me go to Ollie.
Let me share this link.
Awesome. And lastly, Sarah,
we don't want to leave her waiting.
Sarah
Thanks for bringing.
This up,
we're on it
in the fix.
Is on the way
I think it deserves some
applause.
This is real, OK? Like this is real.
I have
a video demo here in case the internet would,
you know, make up some challenges, but
what you just saw,
the querying, the data, the use case,
all of this
is from a real environment,
OK? No, no, not a simulation or anything
like that. So
What we've just
What we just saw
This is not better observability. This is
how we can actually achieve 10
times better reliability than what we had
until now.
OK? Oli understands your stack. This
is super important.
The reason Ollie was able to do
that in a matter of a minute and come
up with valuable insights and not just made
up ones.
It's because like similar to any engineer you
would hire that would go through training,
when you connect and integrate OLIF
for the very first time,
it learns your observability workspace.
It learns what, which applications you have, what
subsystems,
uh, what are, what fields are present in the
logs,
metrics.
Has it occurred to you that you have 5 metrics,
one with capital case, one with lowercase, they all
mean the same thing.
But they have different naming, so when you query, you
may miss some of them, right, because you
just didn't know
that the casing is so important.
So OLI is familiar with all these fields,
and this is extremely powerful. This is what allows Ollie
really to conduct smart and insightful
investigations. So
In a matter of minutes we found the root cause.
We got a suggestion for a fix.
I think this example is particularly
interesting. Because
the fix here was not.
I don't know, increase CPU or anything like that
or allocate more pods.
This actually was a code
issue. And think about
an on-call,
any on-call, any SRE,
any developer. It doesn't matter
how much, how much experts
they are. With
this,
they could have gotten to the root cause within the lines
of the code,
even if they're not familiar and they haven't seen this
code repository before.
OK, so this is really the true power we're
talking about,
and I think most importantly,
I didn't open even one dashboard.
I didn't filter
any query on my own.
And this is really the true power and the true
potential we have here to achieve 10 times better availability.
Now for those of you here in the crowd and I
see you and some skeptical guys here
thinking, oh yeah, it's just chat GPT
for observability. It's, you know, I saw that.
It's not
OK.
And let me elaborate
what OL is not. So it's not chat GPT for observability
in the sense that OL is not just
chat GPT-like interface
for accessing your observability data. It's
not that.
All it has context,
all he has knowledge, all is autonomous,
meaning in every single, it doesn't have playbooks
in every single point of time.
It decides autonomously
what is the next step.
Ollie is also.
Not an AI assistant.
I'm sure you saw plenty. Every
single company on Earth these days.
Got directive from the CEO we need to add AI
as much as possible, right?
So we see that with AI assistant,
this small cute chatbot you
see on the bottom right usually,
right, like, hey, let me help you.
And these are great, like they do provide a lot of
value, but the value they focus on is
really making you and making
your users
more efficient
within the platform,
right? So if Oli, for example, was an assistant,
It wouldn't do the investigation for you or
with you.
It would actually just help you build
dashboard in core logics.
Um, so it doesn't do that. It's not an AI
assistant. The power, the difference in power
is
not becoming,
I don't know, 20% faster in building dashboards
or alerts.
It's actually becoming 10 times better in reliability,
which is a much broader, higher level
goal for the organization.
Um, and lastly, MCP.
MCP has been around for
quite a while now.
Um, So
Oli is not a server. We do offer for
CoreLogics.
OK, but all is not that. What are the differences?
in a way
is exposing API.
For AI agents, OK. So if I want
to take my, my information,
for example, for, to expose CoreLogics
information to other AI agents like cursor,
I would take
The CoreLogix MCP server,
but it does not have any knowledge. It does
not have any spatial context.
Um, it, it is not
an AI agentic AI system.
So let's understand what OLI is and how OI
works. So
it all starts
with data.
For years
we've been
really focused on how we achieve, store
better data.
And finally, I think really over
a decade that we're
talking about data and the potential value of data, I think
finally we can harness the true value
and the true potential of data.
So CoreLogix is really
good as a platform
for processing, harnessing
tons, massive amounts of data, petabytes
of data, terabytes of data.
That we've
really close to infinite retention.
So all of this is being leveraged by Ollie.
All he learns from this data,
creating a knowledge base,
like he would learn something in school, for example.
And then with this knowledge,
What you saw and saying that you
may say, hey, this is an AI, an
observability agent.
It is not an observability agent because agent
is singular.
Behind the scenes,
Ollie has a team of agents,
specialized agents working for you.
OK, so we have, for example, Logs Explorer.
We have metrics Analyzer.
Each one of them is powered by SLMs.
SLMs are small language models.
Think about 7 billion parameters, 13
billion parameters
that is specialized in the specific
role and specific task at hand,
and they all collaborate together
to produce insights, answers.
Which altogether allow us to get this
10 times better reliability we were talking about.
Now, let's go a step, uh, a step back and talk
in general about any agentic AI
system. I think this is,
if you wanna know how you, what
you can take back home
to your offices, to your work, and
how do you build
your AI agent or your own only.
This is all about that.
So any agentic AI system has 5
main components.
Obviously we can break it down to more, but these are the
core concepts and the core things you
must have in agentic AI system.
So it starts with a model in the center.
OK. Um, which is
clear, this is like the engine
for our agent or our agenttic
system.
We have the system prompt. So for example, you're
an expert in analyzing logs
for this company.
So this is how we provide actual instructions
to our agent.
Then we talked about multiple agents, so we said
logs explorer, right, metrics analyzer,
let's say security
analysts, and so on.
The way they collaborate together.
Could could be different
and it is crucial. So for example,
um, there are different design patterns for it. One architecture
would be that I have one orchestrator
that takes the task. For example,
in this case we ask for investigation.
So the orchestrator is familiar with
all the other agents.
And assign tasks.
Hey Log Explorer,
please find me relevant logs to this issue.
Log Explorer will come back with results.
orchestrator will decide on next steps.
This is one type.
Another type is
handovers.
We can decide, we can
make any sub agent autonomous
so they can play around together as a team.
Like playing ball and at every given
point in time someone else holds the
ball, meaning they are the one leading
the conversation from now on.
So there are different architectures about how
we actually organize our agents.
Then we have the knowledge.
Which talks about
how we provide this, how we empower this
agenttic AI system
not only with tools
but also the knowledge, the information that's
very, very much needed to make smart decisions
and smart actions.
And lastly, but
probably the most important one is the evolve. How do we
actually evaluate the quality
of our agentic system?
So
out of these 5.
What you will notice is model
is commodity.
OK, so,
um. Opus was
released, I think 1 week ago, 2 weeks ago.
We have access to it. All of you have access to
it. GPT 5 got released,
same thing.
So there's nothing really unique about the model. We can,
we all share the same models and same
for system prompt. I can write something, you can write something.
It won't be, it won't make a huge,
huge difference.
So that leaves us with 3 other
main components.
Which together compose what we call the
context engineering triangle.
The context engineering triangle,
this is the key. What you see here, these 3
components.
If you want to build a powerful,
high quality agent.
You need these 3 items and
you need to understand them deeply.
And focus on them.
So we covered about agent architecture and the importance
of agent architecture.
I want to talk a little bit about
knowledge and memory.
So in Chat GPT I think we are all familiar
with the fact that
as we talk with Chat GPT sometimes it
memorizes
what we talked with him about it, right? And
then it can be reused in other conversations.
But one of the challenges
With making the eugenticI system really, really
good. With
knowledge as well
is the limitation of context,
right? In theory,
if I could take all my petabytes of
observability data from the last week
and just push it to all of them and wish them good luck,
I would do that.
But it's not technically possible
as for today.
And I think we can also take here that more is not
more here as well, the fact that it
will have more data.
It does not mean I will get better answers.
So what we do need, we need to
have.
Relevant data,
we have, we need to have it in a structured
way that is optimized for the LLM.
And let me tell you that,
it may sound that
changing models is quite easy, right?
Just within the API call, change the string,
AGPT5.
Now, I want to use cloud,
very easy. In
reality, changing model is difficult.
Um, the reason it's difficult because
different models have different preferences and you
need to optimize the context you're building
accordingly.
So the knowledge needs to be optimized as well.
So going back to we want to build this observability
agent. We need to push
relevant information
to the context,
and we already
agreed we cannot just take all the logs, metrics,
traces, and so on from the last week.
So we need really the way to do
it.
Is actually
the same way as we investigate and as we conduct
an investigation.
Is identify the key parts and
the key elements.
Store them at first.
In the structure, it could be uh whether in vector
DB, knowledge graph,
or just rational DB depending on what
information we store.
And allow our agent to access this
information and the querying part is also key
here because the fact that I have this
information stored somewhere
does not mean
I know how to query it in a, in an
effective way.
So we said, how do we, how do I store
this information? How do I structure it,
and how do I query? These are the three components
when it comes to knowledge
and of how we build
this context.
So let's say we've done these two really, really good. So
we have model,
we have system prompt,
we have some agents architecture, we can do something simple
for starters.
Um, And let's say I saved
some basic aggregations
on my logs
to, to start simple.
The last
Thing which is actually the most important one
is evils. Els is short for evaluation.
Now, in traditional software, we have unit
testing, integration testing, system testing,
right? When we build it, we test,
we see, hey, thumbs up, nothing broke,
all good, we can go live.
A new future comes in.
We implemented.
We build some new tests, run it
again, it all works well.
Ideally we would have done the same
with with AI agents.
The challenge though.
is that there is no structure.
What are we testing?
Right, like we have a conversation, the user
can input whatever they want.
The possibilities are infinite.
Right, like, what do I test?
What happens if the user just come in and
say, Hey, um,
what should I order for lunch?
There are infinite amounts of possibilities
to what the user would put in.
So the question of how do I evaluate it
becomes really, really challenging,
um, and if
not done correctly, or if you actually build an AI agent
and you don't evaluate it at all,
I can show from experience what happens
is.
You build something,
it seems to be working,
right? Even you,
let's say you're very proud, you deploy it to production, you
say to your friends, hey,
I have it, you can start using it
in a matter of minutes, probably you will get some
slack message or someone will tell you,
hey, hey, look, I tried this, it doesn't work.
So, oh, no problem, I'm on it.
You'll go back,
you'll check this very, very specific use case,
and you'll change the system prompt, and guess
what, you will be successful in.
Resolving this use case,
so it seems like we made progress,
but what you didn't realize
is as you change the system prompt, you change
the entire behavior of the agent.
Two things that used to work before
the test that you ran a day ago.
This use case
is not working anymore.
OK.
So
this is why evaluations in AI
agents are no less than crucial.
I will say just one more thing about Evals.
Another challenge here is not only
Testing because it's not just one message.
I got input, output, is it correct or not?
We have an entire flow of conversations.
So how do we test this?
Um, so I, I'll leave it as a food for thought and we can
talk this offline if, if some of you are interested.
Um, so how does that translate into Oli?
So the beautiful thing you saw before, this is
what happens behind the scenes.
Onto the left,
OK, and this is really sharing with you the internals,
how all it works under the hood.
On the left,
OLI is powered by CoreLogic's extremely
powerful observability data platform.
OK. So
notice. Remember I told you OLI
is not an AI system.
That's exactly that.
O is not an expert in
using core logics or using its features to build
dashboards.
It is an expert in helping
you with achieving better reliability and
investigating issues,
optimizing production, and so on.
So it leverages the large scale data
observability platform by CoreLogics.
From it, it takes all these signals
and creates knowledge.
To be honest, like if you were to ask me to choose one
thing or the key
to all these success and quality lies, it's
within the knowledge.
And then we have the collaboration of
the multiple agents. Again, each one
powered by small language model,
which allows us to
get really invaluable production insight as we
saw. So how can you take
it back home and how can you start to build your
own ollie?
So, first thing first,
beta. We need to
store all of our data somewhere blogs, metrics,
traces. The more we have, the better.
Um, but we also need to make sure
that we
build in a structured way that
the agent can actually optimize in that.
The second part is what we call semantic layer.
OK, semantic layer is.
Really, uh, more, uh,
we call it the basic understanding at least of the data.
Let's say I have a field that has the name
CPUSG
70.
What does that mean?
So maybe we can assume it means CPU
usage over the last 7 days
or CPU usage over the last 7 days,
but it's it's important for the agent,
for the, for our engine.
To have this information.
Because this is what allowed the agent
to make smart decisions, say, hey,
I have a problem with CPU. This metric
is actually the metric that would
is likely to be relevant, so maybe I should check this out.
OK, so semantic layer
is, I would call it kind of the first building
block within the knowledge
of the agent.
And the third part is building your first AI
agent MVP.
Take whatever model.
Build it.
They are actually great tools. It's OpenAI
agents at Python SDK,
Linkchain, and others.
Today it became quite easy to come up
with an MVP, so I do recommend really
just getting your hands on.
And try to build this thing.
So and this is just the core
concept to start with.
So from here
We've seen one
Demonstration of how Oli works.
Um, Oli has been in beta for
the last few months with with some of Corologic's
customers.
I do want to share with you
how it actually works, how it actually looks,
um, in real life. So this is a story of one
of our customers.
I was actually fascinated to hear that, to be honest.
So they had a notification
service,
OK. It's a microservice run on, uh,
running on Docker.
That had random latency spikes.
Every now and then, it was really unclear
what's going on.
They look on the logs, they look on the metrics, they
look on the traces, they try to analyze them.
But they couldn't find any correlation
to these latency spikes.
They're really puzzled of
what's going on,
and at some point they say, you know what,
we have no idea.
So let's, let's leave it this
way. Um, after trying out only
for a few weeks,
they say, you know what, let, let's give it a try. We
have nothing to lose, right?
So what happened?
OK. So the first thing they,
that Oli helped them realize is
this notification service
is actually connected to another email service
that's connected to authentication service that's
using RDS.
Now that's interesting because until that point
in time,
they didn't even think or consider
checking for RDS.
Because the service itself has nothing related to
RDS.
OK, so they were looking
in the wrong places.
Now not only that it is connected to RDS,
the reason it is interesting,
um, as identified, all the correlated
spike, spikes in
the CPU,
CPU spikes of the RDS,
amount of connections,
as well as latency spikes of the RDS,
and this was correlated with the spikes of the notification
service.
So for the very first time after 4 months,
they got some clue of.
We have at least more understanding of what's
going on. No, the
investigation didn't stop there. It was not a one shot. It
was not just one prompter. It was 4
or 5
messages in the conversation.
So the next thing that Oli shared with them.
It has found another lambda
function. That
also works with this RDS function,
uh sorry, with this RDS database.
And the interesting thing is that
This lambda database apparently
this lambda function.
Apparently has also correlation
when it activates
with the spikes of the progress.
OK.
Um, And looking when
Oli looked on the queries that were running
by this lambda function.
It realizes this, that the queries
were running against unindex tables,
right, which obviously makes, uh,
it creates loads on the RDS
and as a result identification service.
So from here the, the fix was quite obvious. Um,
Oli Ollie also recommended it, but I think it was
quite clear
that the, the fix is really just building indexes
for these tables,
um, but this is fascinating.
Like think about how much time.
would take to find and
investigate and get to the root cause of something like
that. Right, we have
3 services, 1 lambda function, each
one running and managed, being managed by a different
team. RDS they didn't even
think about it as something that could be
related,
um, and in general,
something tricky about lambda functions, right? They
start, they end,
nothing happened,
like they never existed.
Um, so
this is a real case,
super interesting. 4 months, this,
this issue was unsolved.
Tripoli, less than 10 minutes,
they realized what's going on.
So we talked about the power
of reliability. We talked about
the fact that our focus was in the
wrong place.
We're running after observability.
We forgot
to chase after reliability.
So how do we move from here? OK,
we're still in the early days of AI.
And what you see, so in
the last decade, I would say observability
has
increased and has
Kind of evolved in a linear way.
We've added more features. We've had user sessions,
RAM, more capabilities, obviously and more features,
so we have improved but not
exponentially.
This is the first step what I'm just presenting you.
This is just the first step
in the paradigm shift we're experiencing.
The first milestone is co-pilot.
So just to clarify, it's not here to replace
anyone. It's here to help us make our work,
make our job much, much better,
and to allow us to focus on what really matters.
The next step
for Ollie.
And, and by the way, it's like
a few weeks from uh
getting the first release of it.
It's being proactive.
What does that mean? It means two things. One,
it means when an alert fires on Slack,
only automatically triage and
provide you with
initial understanding of what's going on.
The second part of being proactive.
Is really allowing OE to
take actions,
all right. Maybe it's
just pull request,
maybe it's just changing our
AWS environment.
So this is the next step. This is the proactive phase
and the holy or holy grail.
Is getting to preventive observability.
OK, now think about it. This is
An ideal.
Think about an agent, and I think we've been talking about
this vision for years now,
but for the very first time it seems possible
to get to a point where we have an agent
that constantly watches our production,
whether it's from a product standpoint, whether it's from
a cost standpoint,
operations, infrastructure, and so
on and so forth. It is familiar
with the way it works in general. It is familiar
with seasonality
and it can say, hey, listen.
We expect to see an increase in loading in
the next few days.
We have 80% utilization.
We have to increase the amount of pods and take action
and actually increase this amount of pods,
preventing
a downtime or delay for users.
So this is really where we're going with that.
And with that, I'm really happy to share that
OLLI is now generally
available for all of CoreLogic's customers.
Um, we started rolling this out and by December
15th, will be publicly available for all of
our users.
So
I think we covered a lot of points,
um. Whether
it's the fact that the software stack
has changed.
Um, I really remember, you know,
10 years ago
when you build an app, it was just one single
application. It was a web application.
You were running it on one
web server.
And that's it. And maybe you had some blogs
written somewhere
to help you debug it,
so it was much, much, much easier, much
convenient. But now we have microservices
and we have server loss and we have so many text
tech and so many moving parts,
all of them creating
so many breadcrumbs.
So we have to find a better way
to achieve software reliability.
This is not a feature
All the autonomous observability. This is
not the future. It's not
just something cool.
It's really a paradigm shift.
It's really a change of the way
we think, the way we work, the way we act,
and the time is now.
It is not something futuristic. What you saw is
already working.
Proactive
is really,
let's say 2 or 3 months away,
so the time to adopt this solution,
the time to implement those solutions is really
now. We have this opportunity
to make our software much, much better, to
make our work better.
And with that, I want, I wanna thank you. I'm
happy to take questions
afterwards. I'm not sure if we have time.
Uh, yeah, just, uh, we, we got like
a few minutes for questions if anyone wants. Um,
we're very happy.